françois mitterrand qui poursuit sa
visite officielle à moscou avait
aujourd'hui un tour du côté des étoiles
sur place dominique le replay nos
envoyés spéciaux
spectacle insolite est exceptionnel pour
françois mitterrand des cosmonautes à
l'entraînement retrouve dans l'eau les
conditions exactes da pesenti le
président de la république et miral leur
badge of leurs épouses en compagnie de
valentina terechkova la première femme
cosmonaute et jean loup chrétien ont
passé un après midi à la cité des
étoiles
c'est ici que jean loup chrétien a
préparé la première mission spatiale
font tout ce biais c'était fantastique
caen l'a souvent dit la volée avec nous
et maintenant nous le connaissons tous
très bien et si françois mitterrand
attend demain matin pour s'exprimer
devant la presse
mirel gorbatchev s'est livré à quelques
réflexions vers les jo analystes
monsieur gorbatchev
que pensez vous des relations franco
soviétique sur l'espace nous ont juste
d'en parler avec le président nous
sommes tombés d'accord pour que notre
coopération pour l'expression pacifique
du kosovo en perspective il mettra
rocher perspective
une anecdote pour conclure qui résume
bien le climat détendu de cette
rencontre
en quittant la cité des étoiles monsieur
gorbatchev a déclaré en souriant
nous venons d'effectuer le second vol
franco-soviétique prélude